اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الساعه الجديده
والتي نخصص معظمها لتطورات الاحداث في
السودان وروسيا
20 يوما اذا مشاهدينا من الحرب في السودان
وما زالت الاشتباكات مستمره بين الطرفين
المتنازعين على السلطه الجيش والدعم
السريع قتال وصف بالاعنف منذ بدايه
الاحداث رغم اعلان اتفاق مبدئي لتمديد
الهدنه وواصل الطرفان مسلسله تبادل
الاتهامات بخرق الهدن مسلسل يرافقه اسف
امامي لاخفاق المنظمه في وقف الحرب هذا
وثقت صحه السودانيه اكثر من 200 وفاه
والاف الاصابات بل الاف الاصابات حتى الان
وهذه مشاهدينا صور مباشره من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم في
ظل هذه المواجهات بين قوات الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع التي وصلت الى يومها
العشرين واسبوعها الثالث على التوالي
ونشاهد ايضا من بعيد اعمده الدخان التصاعد
في بعض المناطق جراء هذه الاشتباكات وكذلك
الاتهامات والاتهامات المضاده بخرق الهدى
بين طرفي النزاع والاجهزه السودانيه
مشاهدين ايضا اليوم كان قد اعلن تدمير
عربات قتاليه للدعم السريع في الساعات
الاولى من صباح هذا اليوم وايضا اعلن
احباطه محاوله
لتعزيز قوته في محيط القصر الجمهوري الدعم
السريع ايضا مشاهدينا اتهم الجيش في هذا
اليوم بمهاجمه قواته واحياء سكنيه ايضا
وكل ذلك ياتي في وضع انساني بات كارثيا
وترافقه ايضا تحذيرات دوليه من ان الاسواق
ربما يكونوا قادما ومتحد ايضا مشاهدين
امينها العام اسفه لما وصفته باخفاقها في
وقف الحرب في السودان واستمرار خرق هذه
الهدن ومازن معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه
الصور المباشره من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ونشاهد من بعيد
ارتفاع اعمده الدخان بسبب الاشتباكات
الدائره بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني وكما نتابع الان مراسل العربيه
يقول ان قوات من الجيش السوداني تمشط
منطقه كوبر في بحري بعد السيطره عليها
افاد مراسل العربيه مشاهدينا بندراع معارك
عنيفه في الخرطوم حيث دوت الانفجارات منذ
الصباح في محيط القصي الجمهوري والقياده
العامه للجيش مراس العربي تاكد ايضا ان
الخرطوم تشهد اشتباكات هي الاعنف منذ بدء
الصراط هذا وتشهد العاصمه تحريق للطيران
الحربي للجيش بشكل مكثف اما في ام درمان
فتشهد المدينه اطلاقا كثيفا لقباء في
المدفعيه بين الجانبين
هذا واظهر الصور اقمار صناعيه حريقا في
مطار الخرطوم الدولي مع استمرار المواجهات
[موسيقى]
لن تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخرق الهدنه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي اخرها اتهام
بيان الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن قصف
عشوائي على عدد من مواقع تمركز قواتها
وبعض الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه الجديده
التي بدا سريانها اليوم مؤكده على ان
القصف الذي شناه الجيش بالمدافع والطائرات
يشكل تجاوزا للاعراف والقوانين الدوليه في
المقابل اكد الجيش ان قوات الدعم السريع
حاولت الهجوم على قياده منطقه بحر
العسكريه واضاف الجيش السوداني ان قواته
دمرت عددا من العربات القتاليه التابعه
لدعم السريع واستلمت خمس عربات تم تركها
في ميدان المعركه
هذا وكشف المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه
السودانيه الدكتور محمد ابراهيم العربيه
عن توقف 93 مستشفى عين الخدمه من اصل 130
في مناطق النزاع مؤكدا ان هناك اكثر من
200 حاله وفاه جراء الاشتباكات تم توثيقها
حتى الان
عدد الاصابات 3420 اصابه في الغطاءين
العام الخاص الوفيات وسبعه حاله وفاه في
الغطاء عين العام الخاص وهذه موثقه اما
بتحويل الى المشرحه او شهادات الوفاء هذه
من واقع السجلات الطبيه
والارقام الاحصائيه بالمؤسسات الصحيه
بالنسبه لعدد المستشفيات في ولايه الخرطوم
يوجد 134 مستشفى عام يتبع للغطاء العام
والقطاع الخاص هذه المستشفيات موزعه على
السبع محليات التي تشكل ولا تخلطون
الذي يعمل فيها منها
ثلاثه وتسعين مستشفى بخروج عدد اتنين
مستشفى اليوم
اظهرت لقطات جويه تصاعد الدخان في المواقع
التي يعتقد ان قيادات لدعمركز فيها في
الخرطوم بحري مقابل القصيه الجمهوري
وتحديد وتحديدا في حي حله حمد والمنطقه
الصناعيه وحي الاملاك
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من خرطوم ينضموا الصحفي محمد شمس
الدين اهلا بك محمد معنا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه لماذا اشتباكات اليوم هي الاعنف
مقارنه بالايام السابقه ما الذي استجد وما
الذي يعنيه وصول الاوضاع الى هذه المرحله
تحياتي لك احمد ولسات المشاهدين اينما
كانوا يعني اشتداد المعارك في ثلاثه ايام
الاخيره هناك بعض الخبراء الذين ينسبونها
الى ربما اقتراب مواعيد
التفاوض الذي ربما يكون قد بدا بشكل غير
مباشر ما بين الطرفين وفي مكان غير معلوم
حتى هذه اللحظه رشحت انباء عن بعض المواقع
التي قد ربما تكون فيها الجوله الاخيره من
المباحثات لكنها ايضا غير مؤكده حتى هذه
اللحظه وابرز هذه المواقع او المدن هي
مدينه جده في غرب السعوديه
بطبيعه الحال هذه المعارك على الرغم من
اعلان الهدن
الطرفين التزامهما
بتفاصيل الهدن فيما يتعلق بفتح الممرات
الانسانيه ونقل المواد الاغاثيه وما الى
ذلك الا ان
العسكريه دائما ما تشدد على مساله حقها في
الرد على اي من الخروقات التي تحصل من قبل
قوات الدعم السريع وبناء على ذلك فان جميع
الهدن السابقه لم يعني
تحظى بالهدوء المطلوب والذي يبحث عنه
المواطنون السودانيون بطبيعه الحال جراء
كل عمليه من العمليات تكون هناك اضرار
الجانبيه بكل اسف شديد يعني تكون هناك
حصيله من الضحايا من المدنيين الذين
يسكنون في مناطق تكون قريبه من مواقع
الاشتباكات او مواقع القصف الجوي او القصف
المتبادل بالمدافع في مختلف مواقع مدن
العاصمه القصف المكثف اليوم
تركز في مناطق محيط القياده العامه
والاحياء الشرقيه للمطار وكذلك الاحياء
الغربيه القريبه من القياده العامه
في محيط القصر الجمهوري ومن الناحيه
الاخرى شرق الخرطوم او شرق
يعني هذه المنطقه حي حله حمد والاملاك
يعني ولا للشوارع المؤديه الى شرق وصولا
الى الى كبري الحديد وسلاح الاشاره كل هذه
المواقع شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه ومكثفه لمده
ربما
هذه الاشتباكات يعود ربما الى مساله قرب
الجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات بين الطرفين
لكن المتابع ايضا لتصريحات البرهان ودلو
مع حفظ الالقاب مع وسائل الاعلام المختلفه
منها العربيه يلحظ عزمه واصرار كل طرف على
فرض رؤيته وحضوره في المشهد وازاحه الاخر
تماما هل استشفيت في حديث رجلين جديه حول
مساله التفاوض
يعني من التصريحات يبدو ان هناك استخداما
واضحا للمصطلحات في
الجاهزيه لمساله ايقاف الحرب
وبعض يعني التصريحات او بعض التعبيرات
تشير الى ايضا
الجديه في مواصله هذه العمليه هناك حاله
من حالات التضارب والتناقض في التصريحات
على الرغم من ان يعني بعض القراءات تشير
الى ان المعركه ربما تكون قد اقتربت من
نهايتها لكن
هناك من يرى ايضا ان هناك تضاربا في مراكز
القرار في المؤسسه العسكريه
من حيث التصريحات والبيانات التي تصدر من
الجهات الرسميه المرتبطه بالجيش سواء مكتب
الناطق الرسمي او حتى تصريحات القاده
العسكريين الذين تحدثوا لارسال الاعلام
خلال الايام الماضيه كل هذه التفاصيل تشير
الى ان هناك ربما اشكاليه في
عمليه التواصل مع وسائل الاعلام او
التنسيق في المواقف الداخليه
فيما يتعلق بقياده المؤسسه العسكريه هذا
ما يصير هذه تساؤلات التي قد لا تكون
يعني او قد لا توجد لها اجابات على ارض
الواقع هناك تصريحات تفيد بان هناك سيطره
كامله على محيط القصر على سبيل المثال ومن
ثم تظهر لقطات بعد ذلك بقليل على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي تفيد بعكس ذلك ولا توجد
عمليه تاكيد وهناك تصريحات عده لدعم ايضا
محمد يتحدث فيها عن ان قواته سيطرت على
90% من العاصمه الخرطوم يعني هذا يعني ان
الجيش السوداني يسيطر فقط على 10% باختصار
انك تعلق على هذه الجزئيه
في مناطق واسعه من الاحياء الشرقيه وايضا
شهود العيان يثبتون ان هذه القوات ايضا
تتواجد في مناطق في غرب العاصمه لكن هناك
مواقع فعلا حدث فيها تقدم من قبل قوات
الجيش لاسيما هذا الموقع الذي حدثت فيه
الاشتباكات اول المواقع التي حدثت فيها
الاشتراكات اليوم ولقطات التي ظهرت بعد
ذلك تثبت ذلك لكن مساله عدم تمكن الصحافه
من تغطيه هذه المعارك بطريقه محايده
وطريقه شفافه يعني تؤدي الى هذه
حالا من حالات التضارف الانباء وعدم
امكانيه التحقق عن قرب وعن كثب خاصه في ظل
عدم وجود الوسيله الاعلاميه الاولى التي
تغطي ايضا وهي التلفزيون الرسمي
من خارج مقر التلفزيون والذي غير معلوم
حتى الان اذا ما تمت استعاده مقر
التلفزيون والاذاعه ام لا على الرغم ان
هناك معركه في تلك ربما نسال عن هذه
الجزئيه زميلنا مقداد حسن الذي سيكون معنا
بعد قليل شكرا لك من درمان الصحفي الصحفي
عفوا محمد شمس الدين
الان معنا من الاندرمان الصحفي مقداد حسن
اهلا بكم مقداد الجزئيه الاخيره التي تحدث
عنها زميل محمد شمس الدين حول تساؤله عن
وضع مبنى التلفزيون لدعوه التلفزيون يعني
هل هو تحت سيطره الجيش ام سيطره قوات
الدعم السريع
نعم بحسب تواصلاتنا مع القاطنين في تلك
المنطقه والقريبين جدا من محيط الهيئه
العامه للاذاعه والتلفزيون ان قوات الدعم
السريعه تنتشر حول محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون وحول الاحياء المحيطه بها
بمنطقه بروف والملازمين كذلك وان بعض
العمارات التي يسكن التي كان يسكنها
مواطنين قد دخلت فيها قوات الدعم السريع
وكذلك قد سمعنا بتصريحات المتحدث باسم
وزاره الصحه ان مستشفى الوداد وهي ايضا من
المستشفيات التي تقع في محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون ليست ببعيده من الهيئه العامه
ايضا بها تواجد لقوات الدعم السريع وكانت
بالامس ايضا انتشرت قوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق واسعه من الاحياء المحيطه بهذه
المنطقه وكذلك ايضا بحسب من تواصلنا معهم
ان هذه القوات تتواجد في منطقه الغربيه
لامدرمان تحديدا في المنصوره وغرب منطقه
المهندسين وكذلك تمتد حتى
المناطق القريبه من سوق ليبيا اما السوق
في حد ذاته لا توجد به قوات الدعم سريع
وهو يمارس او يمارس المواطنون هنالك
اعمالهم بصوره شبه طبيعيه في تلك الاسواق
ما يؤرق المواطنين في هذه التحركات
العسكريه ان هنالك اعمال سلب والنهب
انتشرت من العصابات المتفلته في كثير من
المناطق خاصه منطقه السوق الشعبي التي
شهدت كثير من الاعتداءات على المحلات
التجاريه ومحلات الاعمال التي يعمل منها
المواطنون وهنالك عمليات سلب واسعه حتى
حتى منطقه الثوره التي تعتبر منطقه شبه
امنه او فيها الحركه بصوره طبيعيه هنالك
انبات تتحدث عنه ان بنك الخرطوم في في
شارع النص تحديدا في محطه السابع كان قد
تعرض لعمليه او محاوله عمليه الاعتداء في
الليله السابقه لكن المواطنين وبحسب
الشهود عيان انهم قد تصدوا لهذا الهجوم
والمواطنون عموما في قد الثوره والمناطق
المحيطه كانوا قد انشاوا لجان تحاول ان
تحمي مداخل الاحياء وتمشط بمجهودات شعبيه
لحفظ الامن وهذا مقداد يدفع للتساؤل يعني
حول اين هي قوات الشرطه يعني والتي اعلنت
قبل ايام انها قد نشرت قوات الاحتياط
المركزيه التابعه لوزاره الداخليه لحفظ
الامن في العاصمه بمدنها الثلاث
نعم سمعنا ان قوات الشرطه وعلمنا من
مواطنين انها تتواجد في مناطق
الشماليه في ام درمان تحديدا سوق صابرين
وهي تنشط حركه
المباحث شرطه المباحث تنشط في تلك المناطق
لكن يتساءل المواطنون ويشتكون من عدم
توجدها في الطرقات لحفظ الامن واستدبابه
خاصه وان هذه القوات في منطقه ام درمان
عنوان كانت لديها ارتكازات واضحه قبل هذه
الاحداث وربما يدفع البعض بالتساؤل وكذلك
قوات الشرطه هي المنوط بها حفظ الامن وحفظ
المنشات العامه والحيويه كانت قد بدات
حملات واسعه في منطقه الخرطوم في المناطق
الجنوبيه امتدادا حتى منطقه سوق الامام
القريبه من
منطقه وسط الخرطوم كانت هنالك تواجد لقوات
الشرطه
بدات تتحرك في في حفظ الامن في مناطق
الخرطوم لكن في مدينه ام درمان يتحدث
البعض ان على انها تتواجد في مناطق متفرقه
ويتساءلون وربما هذا السؤال يوجه لقوات
الشرطه السودانيه ووزاره الداخليه بان
المواطنين يناشدون القوات بان تحفظ الامن
في منطقه السوق ام درمان والسوق الشعبي
والمناطق المتاخمه لهذه
المحلات التي يعتقد ان تحدث فيها اشتباكات
وتفلتات من عصابات السلب والنهب وبالتالي
هذا ما يلقي سلبا على على الاوضاع
الانسانيه والاوضاع المعيشيه اليوميه التي
يواجهها المواطنون في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه الخرطوم هل هناك نقاط احتكاك بين
الدعم السريع وقوات الاحتياطي المركزي
التابع لداخليه
لا وجود لهذه
الاحتكاكات بحسب البيانات الصادره من قوات
الشرطه لا وجود للاحتكاكات هنا في منطقه
الخرطوم وكان اخرها قد حدث في منطقه وسط
السوق العربي في اثراء المعركه التي حدثت
بالامس لكن في مدينه ام درمان لم تصدر اي
بيانات او اي يعني شهود عيان تحدثوا عن
وجود اشتباكات بين هيئه عمليات الشرطه او
الاحتياط المركزي مع مع قوات الدعم السريع
او اي من المواطنين او اي من عمليات من
العصابات السلب والنهب التي تنتشر بكثافه
هذه الايام كيف يمكن وصف اوضاع المستشفيات
في ام درمان مقداد يعني وماذا عن مستشفيات
الرئيسيه هل تقدم خدماتها بشكل جزئي او لا
تقدم خدمتها نهائيا في هذا التوقيت
نعم المستشفيات تنظر من جزء منها يعمل
بشكل شبهي كامل وشبه والبعض الاخر قد اغلق
ابوابه خاصه وان الاوضاع
الانسانيه والاوضاع الامنيه تحديدا تحد من
حركه الكوادر الطبيه والمعينات الطبيه
التي يمكن ان تصل الى المستشفيات هنالك
مستشفى في في مدينه ام درمان تحديدا في حي
العمده مستشفى الندى هذا المستشفى يعمل
بالطاقه كامله في عمليات الولاده القيصريه
وهو كان قد اجرا اكثر من 300 عمليه في هذه
المستشفى بمجهودات ربما هي شبه شعبيه
ومنظمات كذلك من خارج البلاد وكذلك مستشفى
انه هو ايضا من المستشفيات التي تعمل
بمبادرات شبابيه ومبادره من الكادر الصحي
وهنالك نداءات واستغاثات ومبادرات تدعو
الى دعم الموقف الصحي والموقف وموقف
الكادر الطبي في على العموم وهذا ايضا
يلقي بظلاله على الجوانب الاخرى الحياتيه
من الماء والكهرباء هنالك جهود شعبيه
كبيره تقوم بايصال المحطات المياه ومراجعه
خطوط الكهرباء وبالامس القريب شاهدنا ذلك
في منطقه حي الشرفيه ان غرفه الطوارئ التي
هي بمجهود شعبي كانت قد اطلقت نداوه
وبالتالي استجابت استجاب المهندسون وفقا
نداءات شعبيه لهذه العمليات وتم ارجاع
الامداد الكهربائي في مناطق ام درمان
القديمه ومنطقه حي الشرفيه وبالتالي
المواطنون الان يحاولون ان يبذلوا قصار
جهدهم حتى يعني تتم عمليات الحياه بصوره
شبه طبيعيه مع مجهودات كبيره جدا وجباره
من الشباب والمبادرات الشبابيه والكوادر
الطبيه ومجموعات
المجتمعه الانساني في المنطقه عموما لكن
على العموم اذا ما استمر الحال على ما هو
عليه ربما هذا ينذر بكارثه انسانيه هي
الاسوا في في منطقه في في عموم ولايه
الخرطوم لانقطاع هذه
السلاسل الامداديه من الوقود ومن المواد
الغذائيه ومن الغاز ومن كل الاسئله على
الاستراتيجيه التي ربما تشهد انقطاع شبه
كامل في جميع مناطق ام درمان وحتى الان
نحن نتحدث عن عن سوق سوداء في جميع
وارتفاع جنوني في الاسعار في جميع المواد
الغذائيه بالنسبه لان هذا المخزون الذي
يستخدم الان هو اصلا كان يعني من من قبل
ان تحدث هذه الاحداث وايضا هو موجود
بالمستشفيات وبالصيدليات وبالمخابز وكذلك
القطاعات العامه والمحال التجاريه واذا ما
استمر الحاله على ما هو عليه يخشى
المواطنون من ان تتفاقم الازمه وان يكون
هنالك شحفي السيول النقديه والشح في جميع
معينات الحياه والسلع الاستراتيجيه التي
يمكن ان تهدد امنهم واستقرارهم واستذبابهم
وتحدثت قبل قليل اذا لاحظت الاصدقاء يقول
انه اذا ما استمر الحال على ما هو عليه في
منطقه ام درمان الشماليه التي هي تشهد
الحياه فيها بصوره شبه طبيعيه ربما هو
يفكر بالنزوح اذا ما استمر هذا الحال لان
الاوضاع الامنيه تزداد خطوره والاوضاع
المعيشيه تزدع تزداد بصوره غير يعني
مناسبه تلائم الحياه الانسانيه في منطقه
وكذلك هذا في المناطق الاخرى من بحر من
بحر والخرطوم وعموم ولايه السودان نعم
كنت معنا الصحفي مقداد حسن تحيه مقداد
نطلع مشاهدينا هذه الاخبار العاجة الوارده
على شاشه العربيه نقلا عن البيت الابيض
يقول امريكا لا تشجع او تمكن اوكرانيا من
ضرب اهداف خارج حدودها يقول ايضا البيت
الابيض ادعاء روسيا بان واشنطن وراء
الهجوم على الكرمنين خاطئه
بالعوده الى سياق هذه الساعه الاخباريه
مشاهدينا وفي الاثناء نشر الجيش السوداني
مقطعا مصورا للمركبات ولاسلحه تابعه للدعم
السريع بعد اشتباكات اخيره في محيط سلاح
الاشاره بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
في اول تعليق رسمي بخصوص الوساطات الدوليه
لانهاء الصراع في السودان قاره المتحدث
باسم الخارجي الاثيوبيه ان بلاده تدعم
جهود ووساطه الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي ومنظمه الايجاد معتبرا ان الجهد
الاحاديه الاخرى ستؤذن الوضع في السودان
الوضع الحالي في السودان ستكون له تاثيرات
سلبيه علينا نتابع الوضع السوداني بقلق
بالغ ونؤكد تاييدنا دور الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه ايجاد في
الوساطه بين اطراف الصراع السوداني ونؤمن
بان الحوار هو الحل الوحيد للازمه هذا
واظهر الصور اقمار صناعيه حريقا في مطار
الخرطوم الدولي مع استمرار المواجهات
[موسيقى]
في تصريحات للعربي اعرب السفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي في القاهره كريستيان عن قلقه من
الحرب في السودان واضاف ان تعامل بحرص على
حدودها مبرر حتى لا يتسلل الارهابيون
اليها
نحن قلقون عندما تدور اشتباكات مثل هذه
وتتحول الى حرب لان هذا يعطي المساحه
دائما لذوي الافكار المتطرفه والارهابيه
اننا نرى ما تفعله مصر الان وهي تتعامل
بحرص على الحدود لتتاكد من عدم تسرب
ارهابيين من خلال حدودها مع السودان
واعتقد اننا سنناقش هذا على المستوى
الثنائي مع نظرائنا المصريين لنرى امكانيه
التعاون في هذا الموضوع
هذا ويواصل مئات السودانيين نزوحهم نحو
مصر فارينا من المعارك المستمره بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وفي الايام
الماضيه شهدت المعابر البريه الجنوبيه بين
مصر والسودان تزاحما شديدا لعبور عشرات
الحافلات التي تقل السودانيين والاجانب
المقيمين في البلاد الى مصر
نشكر الشعب المصري
العربيه على حسن الاداء والضيافه
والمعامله ولكن في بعض النواقص مشيره
اليها تكدس عالي جدا يحتاج الى خدمات اسرع
الناس جايه بتنشن عالي جدا بمنك
يعني مناوله ومداوله الامر باسرع في تقدس
كثير في حلفا في هذه المشكله حاسد بتقابل
بتقابل
يعني اعتمر عالغينهم العالقين بجمهوريته
يعني جمهوريه مصر العربيه هم قاعدين نحسب
حلفا يعني شغال من السودان برفع مواطنين
من المعبر للسوداني لابو سمبل
الحركه شويه اليومين دي يعني صعبه يعني مع
الحروبات والمشاكل هذا هو ظهرت لقطته
فيديو لمركبات اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر في شوارع العاصمه الخرطوم حيث
تتفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه والطبيه جراء
استمرار للمواجهات
مشاهدينا من مدينه بورسودان ينضم الينا
مراسله العربيه النزار البقدزاوي اهلا بك
نزار وما الذي الت اليه الاوضاع الانسانيه
والخدميه في بورسودان
اذا فقدنا الاتصال مع زميل نزار وسنعود
اليك مره اخرى في سياقها
في السودان في توقف حركه الاف من شاحنات
نقل البضائع من الميناء الرئيسي في مدينه
بورسودان الى مختلف الولايات السودانيه
الشاحنات التي تحمل رقمها والوقود والمواد
الاساسيه يشكو اصحابها من تطاول امد
الازمه في وقت وضعت فيه حكومه ولايه البحر
الاحمر خططا عاجله للتعامل مع الاوضاع
الراهنه ومن بينها اجلاء رعايا الدول
الاجنبيه عبر شرق السودان
المواجهه المسلحه القت بظلال سلبيه على
قطاعات حيويه ومهمه في البلاد هنا في شرق
السودان تبرز معاناه سائق الشاحنات
المتوقفين عن العمل كواحده من تداعيات
الاوضاع الامنيه في السودان
والله المشكله انه العربات دي شاحنه
والطبع الوضع ما منه
يعني عندنا طلعت
اول نقطه بدات عبور ونرجعها على اساس
البلد ما في عمل
دي اكبر مشكله في العالم يعني هسه نحن
عندنا ناس قاعدين من
نص رمضان لغايه الان ما قادرين تتحرك هو
عربات شحن وقاعده بس
زي ما شايفين حديد اهو شاحن واقف والله
شاحنين دقيق
وازاء هذا الوضع تدفع غرف النقل بولايه
البحر الاحمر بمطالبها وتتحدث عن خسائر
باهظه كمرحين اصحاب شاحنات
القطاع فيه وفوق الكم
تقريبا متوقف نسبه تسعين او زياده يعني
هذا من جانب اما بقيه الملفات الخدميه
والتنمويه فان السلطات في ولايه البحر
الاحمر تؤكد العمل على استقرار الاوضاع
والتعاطي بايجابيه مع قضيه ايلاء رعايه
الدول الاجنبيه الوضع الامني بصفه عامه
على مستوى العشره محليات
الامن في هذه الولايه يمكن الحياه تصير
بصوره طبيعيه كما شاهدتموها
ايضا الاسواق النشاط التجاري بصوره ممتازه
الحياه بصوره طبيعيه ما شاء الله ما عندنا
مشاكل اياميه يمكن بالاخوه
السودان نحن عن طريق التنسيق مع منظمات
المجتمع المدني في مدينه
الان تم اعداد ما يقارب سبعه مناطق منتشره
فيها كل الخدمات مما شرب ووجبات يمكن
ثلاثه وجبات تقدم
البرنامج السري بصوره ممتازه جدا نزار
البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث من مدينه
بورسودان شرقي السودان
حضر والي ولايه شمال دارفور من وقوع كارثه
انسانيه بمخيمات النازحين بعد ان قامت
المنظمات الامميه العامله في المجال
الانساني باجراء موظفيها بسبب تدهور الوضع
الامني وقال ان الوضع الانساني بالولايه
ينذر بكارثه حقيقيه قبل ان يعرب عن قلق
حكومته تجاه تطورات الحاصله وعلى الصعيد
الامني اكد والي ولايه شمال دارفور ان هدف
الولايه الاستراتيجي هو المحافظه على وقف
اطلاق النار الذي توصل اليه الطرفان
بواسطه لجنه الحكماء مؤخرا
اوضاع صعب يعيشها اكثر من 300 سائق شاحنه
وقود و19 عاملا اجنبيا في محطات توليد
الكهرباء الواقعه في مركز قوات الدعم
السريع حيث قام وفد من حكومه جنوب دارفور
وتحديدا مدينه النيال بمتابعه اوضاعهم
والعمل مع الشرطه والدعم السريع التي
تكفلته بتامين العاملين الاجانب وحمايتهم
من النهب اضافه الى فتح الطرقات وترحيل من
ينوي المغادره الى بلاده
احنا زياره دي تمت يعني بناء على المبادره
واخواننا ديل في الكهرباء واخواننا
الاتراك واخواننا السائق اللواري اللي
بيحملوا حقيقه الوقود من بورسودان لنيال
يعني هلقيت تجيني فقدنا اهوالهم وشفناهم
والان احنا في مسقعه انه كيف يفتح الطريق
عشان كل الناس
الكميه من الشكاوي يعني تعرضوا يمكن
مثل هذا المشاكل اكيد يعني كل زول نصيبه
من الشيل حصل له يعني ولذلك يحتسبون لله
لكن خلاص الناس قادرين انه يقفوا معاهم
لحد ما يرجى باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى
فاننا امرنا في الله كبير ونعمل في علم
السودان كلها يعني باذن الله سبحانه
حتى الناس كلهم توقف صوت الصله وتحتك لصوت
الاكل من السودان محتاج الان للحزه
السودان محتاج لسويد ابو ناوي يعني يعني
تعرضنا لحاله والله بتجيد صعبه صعبه بكل
صعوبه يعني سته ايام مرت علينا قبل كده ما
حصلت علينا سته ايام
وبفضل الاله وبحمد الله ومن بعده لاخواننا
في الدعم السريع والله هم يعني انقذونا
ادعمونا ماديا ومع نبيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات